and then start all right um welcome to
the ddps seminar everyone before we
introduce our invited speaker let's go
over some rules and Logistics uh first
please mute yourself during the talk but
if you have questions you can unmute and
ask your questions or use chat room to
post your questions so that we can
address them in Q&A session at the end
second uh today's ddps seminar is open
to external audience
um therefore uh no classified discussion
is allowed finally The Talk today will
be recorded and uploaded in our YouTube
channel that's about it now let me uh
introduce our speaker today it is an
honor to host Dr mangu guo who is an
assistant professor in Applied
Mathematics at the University of quent
uh the Netherlands prior to this
appointment he held post-doctoral
positions at epfl's Institute of
mathematics and the Odin Institute for
computational uh engineering and
Sciences at UT Austin he received his uh
Bachelor's in engineering and PhD
degrees in civil engineering both with
top honors from uh singua University in
2013 and
2017 uh his research interest spent
several are areas areas uh in
computational engineering Sciences of
course exciting areas including modor
reduction uh
vuq multifidelity data fusion and
probabilistic methods for scientific
machine learning uh currently he
receives a financial support from Dutch
national instrument uh sector plan beta
under the focus area mathematics of
computational science today uh mangu uh
will present an exciting topic which is
probability realistic methods for
datadriven reduced Auto modeling I'm
sure uh we will hear an exciting talk
today but before I pass the button to
mangu let me ask a couple of questions
to him just to get to know him better
and make this seminar somewhat informal
okay first question here you go um in
your bio you have listed several
research interest like model reduction
ukq multifidelity data fusion and
probabilistic methods for scientific
machine learning Etc yeah I know they
are all related but if you have to
choose one that is the most exciting to
you right now what what is it and
why uh if I have to choose I I don't
prefer but if I have to choose I would
choose ukq uh I think especially in the
current ERA of scientific machine
learning ukq is a cross section right
across scientific Computing
computational statistics machine
learning learning uh physics based
simulation and ddps right so I think the
crossroad is ukq and I'm the most
excited about it I'm also teaching ukq
to the master students and they are also
quite uh interested in ukq topics yeah
awesome awesome I guess you're going to
say ukq Conference next year yeah
indeed a very nice city yeah I will see
you there then um second question here
we go how is like being a professor at
the University uh of TW uh the
Netherlands if I give you a minute to
advertise your University here to
audiences how would you brag about your
school yeah this is a very International
University uh it's in uh it's inside the
nland is in the middle of Europe but all
of our teaching no matter Bachelor level
or Master Level everything is in English
so we have a variety of uh students uh
from all the countries you can think of
and the the diversity and inclusion is
perfect here so I welcome a lot of uh
students from from us and from China
from all the countries uh to to to our
University to have Bachelor or Master
studies or phds and this is definitely
one of the best environments you can get
in Europe for uh international studies
and research awesome sounds wonderful
all right um the stage is yours M thank
you thank you uh thank you for the
invitation nice questions and
introduction and uh I value this very
good opportunity to share some of our uh
re research results on problemistic
method for datadriven redu on modeling
uh some established resour uh results
and some more uh uh recent results uh I
often like to uh start my uh motivation
uh by talking a little bit about digital
twin and
Technologies uh you know digital
twinning is currently a very trendy
Topic in the computational
engineering uh community and when we
talk about a digital twin we are
actually referring to a digital replica
that persistently represents a unique
physical asset throughout its uh life
cycle uh powered by Big Data and enabled
by a dynamical synchronization between
the physical and the digital Twins and
in my personal opinion uh the success of
digital twinning would highly rely on
the synergistic integration of Basics
based modeling and machine learning
together with real world observational
data and this is actually perfectly
aligned with the spirit of scientific
machine learning and in order to realize
the dynamical real time synchronization
between the physical and digital twins
uh it is crucial to to realize to enable
a multiquery realtime
simulations as I guess most of you uh
already know in scientific Computing uh
multiquery real time simulations are
often described by a nonlinear time
dependent possibly also uh parametric
partial differential equations uh if we
use full order solvers with detailed
code to solve this multiquery realtime
problems it may result to prohibitive a
computational cost and this is why and
where a reduce a modeling comes into the
stage right so generally speaking model
reduction or reduce order modeling uh
attempts to uh intelligently reduce the
system complexity by representing High
dimensional physical systems uh in low
dimensional latent spaces uh just in
case some of the audience may not be
perfectly familiar with Mod reduction uh
just a few words about the general
Spirit of redu all modeling I'm
summarizing uh uh the uh typical
framework for model reduction into three
Rs reduce represent and recover so
typically in the first step we reduce a
high dimensional solution manifold into
a low dimensional latent space and
inside such a latent space we represent
our physical system in a low
dimensionality forming forming our
reduce order system and solve along with
it once we have solved the reduced stage
and in the last step we can recover or
decode back to the full order size right
this is a three-step uh methodology
reduce represent and recover in my
personal opinion uh the most tricky part
is often the Second Step the
representation of the system inside the
low dimensionality in our latent space a
classical treatment for uh this
representation is through a gloring or
Pat of gloring projection we just
project the full order systems into into
the reduced Laten space right and this
classical unconventional treatment
through projection or we call it
projection based motor reduction is
often intrusive meaning that we have to
get the access to the inside of the full
order code to extract the matrixes or
vector or whatever elements we we may
need to formulate our reducer the system
and the numerical projection will also
be problem dependent and this intrusive
nature will most possibly result in
limited industrial relevance which is
not something we want and this has been
my uh and also many other colleagues
motivation to develop datadriven reduce
a the models yeah not interest manner
the Holy Grail in this area is to find
is to learn physically consistent
representations of reduce order Dynamics
primarily from data instead of uh
numerical projection to formulate the
reduce order systems so here I'm quoting
arbert Einstein as far as the laws of
mathematics refer to reality they are
not certain and and as far as they are
certain they do not refer to reality so
basically this has emphasized is it has
pointed out the importance of
uncertainty quantification in scientific
discovery and physical simulations and
of course when we do data driven model
reduction in non intrusive manner when
we do the learning process it is
inevitable to uh uh encounter noise in
the data as well as a variety of
uncertainties um throughout the modeling
process and this has been my motivation
to use problemistic machine learning to
facilitate our datadriven redu all
models
with natural uncertainty
quantification and in the upcoming
perhaps 40ish minutes I'm going to uh
briefly uh review uh some of our
research effort in in the last five six
years until very recent um there are
three classes of methods I would like to
discuss uh depending on how much physics
we are incorporating into the model we
have the first method being blackbox
method basically using Gan process
argate models to build reduce a models
and the second method is a g box method
uh we try to represent reduce order
Dynamic systems with a probabilistic
learning technique called Deep kernel
learning and last but not least we are
going to uh discuss a third method a
glass box method using Basin inference
to estimate reduce all the operators
okay so my journey along this path
started roughly five six years ago in
Switzerland and we started with gion
process surate modeling uh this method
is no longer new uh and maybe it's not
that exact exciting anymore but it did
set basis for a lot of uh followup
considerations in the other method I'm
going to introduce uh so here I would
still like to briefly uh uh discuss this
method a little bit
and also introduce our critical
numerical tool gion process emulation
which will be also used in the other two
method in different ways okay uh so we
started with a very very simple and
straightforward idea the reduce order
modeling often seeks to find a low rank
approximation of the reduced order
Solutions so the reduced order Solutions
will be space time parameter dependent
and it it is actually represented as a
linear combination of a small number of
a reduced basis vectors over space with
a Time parameter combination
coefficients right and to in order to
get the reduced basis vectors we can use
unsupervised learning basically
dimensionality reduction and the most
popular method as you know is a linear
PCA or we call it um proper aong
decomposition in the model reduction
Community we just get the full order
snapshot solution data and compress
through linear PCA and get our reduce
bases vectors and then the question is
about how to approximate the time
parameter dependent combination
coefficients and here we are using a
very simple tool we are using regression
to uh uh to uh approximate the map from
the time parameter inputs onto the uh
projection coefficients onto the uh onto
the reduced basis and the use use this
regression model as a ccate for our uh
expansion coefficients of the P basis
right so one step of unsupervised
learning and another step of supervised
learning and after the training in the
offline stage the online stage is
simulation free we just need to evaluate
the regression output plus a simple
linear combination of the reduced bases
right and in order to further
Improvement the offline training stage
we also tried the multif fedility data
Fusion to reduce the number of high
fedility evaluations to uh improve the
efficiency of the offline stage and also
we tried uh domain decompensation for
accelerations in large scale problems as
I already mentioned the regression tool
we used uh was cion process emulation or
cion process regression uh just in case
you are not uh very familiar with uh
this Tool uh generally speaking uh in
gion process regression we assumed the
prior on the regression function to be a
ging process uh with a given kernel
function perhaps also corrupted by an
additive uh White Noise uh conditioned
on the training data of the input output
pairs we can resort to conditional gausi
and have the posterior distribution also
as a cion process with a new mean
function like this and a new coant uh
function and in this case for our
regression function in a predictive
sense we not only have a mean estimate
but also have the postor variance
providing us with certain uh some kind
of uncertainty quantification as a
confidence level and in order to
determine hyperparameters uh inside as a
gotion process emulation we can use
empirical based method such as
maximizing the marginal likelihood and
on the other hand gion process
regression is a kernel method the
posterior mean estimation is actually
equivalent to the result of a kernel R
regression this means we can also
examine the results of gion process
regression from the perspective of
reproducing kernel Hiers space yeah yeah
an analysis uh sense uh a side note
about this actually uh deep learning or
new networks also uh have connections
with sculping processes uh under certain
assumptions Bas in neuron networks can
be viewed as a gou processes with uh
specifically defined kernels and and as
I just mentioned the government process
regression has close connections uh to
Kernel reach regression and kernel reach
regression is actually function
approximation inside reproducing kernel
heer spaces a class of certain
reproducing kernel hebra spaces uh will
form a baron space and the bar space is
actually a proper function space where
we can investigate the approximation
properties of neuron networks so in this
sense we have a loop uh connecting the
probalistic viewpoints and Analysis
viewpoints of of neuron networks and
government processes right and I believe
out of this Loop uh there can be a lot
of interesting results and uh
observations to be explored and
discovered okay back to our model
reduction game uh we have applied our
cion process based reduce all models
reduce all surrogate models in a variety
of uh applications including those in
computational mechanics like nonlinear
uh structural analysis uh nonlinear
solid mechanics as well
as fluid dynamics and the fluid
structure interaction and more recently
we have been using our reduce or
surrogate models uh in forward and uh
inverse ukq basically uh with our
simulation free online evaluations
through the Gan process arrogates we can
generate however
many how however many uh samples we need
in in ukq estimates if we can have a
good control of our data driven reduce a
model the bias in the uncertainty
estimate would not be so large either
okay so this is our first part using
cion processes uh for serget modeling uh
in the reduce order sense uh so this is
a valid uh option for many applications
because the serget modeling task is very
easy to implement and uh it can work for
many scenarios but I have to admit that
Ser modeling has its limitations is
actually has limitations in predictive
performance because the go process
arrogates were only trying to
approximate U trying to approximate the
reduce other Solutions instead of uh
trying to discover or trying to
represent the Dynamics underly
the data and on the other
hand serget modeling can handle very
well the interpolation of the reduced
man of the solution manifold over the
parametric variation but if we want to
predict for the future States it will
have a lot of
limitations uh from from another
Viewpoint in reality we do we also do
not always have full uh solution vectors
as our data right we may have other uh
forms of observations such as images
photos video and so on and other types
of indirect data as our database and how
do we how can we uh learn reduce all the
low dimensional Dynamics out of this
kind of data is also a question we need
to think about combining this uh
thoughts introduces my second method for
today it is uh reduce all the dynamical
representation out of image data with
deep chal learning and in this work our
research question uh was a little bit
different uh we tried to learn uh low
dimensional latent Dynamics from high
dimensional measurements given by uh
image data and these images are often
corrupted by significant noise since the
noise is uh a lot of noise has been
introduced with especially need need ukq
here right so we are going to use
problemistic machine learning tools for
the uh data driven Discovery and asty
quantification and here you can see an
example uh we have a pendulum swinging
back and forth and we take photos of
such a motion and we TR we can try to
learn the dynamic representation in a
low dimensional manner out of this image
data and this image data are also
corrupted by noise the probalistic
machine learning tool we are going to
use to address this is called Deep
kernel learning in fact deep kernel
learning is a special type of manifold
cion process uh in the sense that the
manifold embedded into the gouin process
kernel is simply a neuron
Network and with with such a setting the
Gan process can take high dimension know
uh data for example images as inputs and
in this sense we can partially overcome
the curse of dimensionality existing in
Gan process emulation and in this case
we also have our neuron Network
parameters trained as gum process
hyperparameters and I would also like to
uh note that the training for such a
deep cral learning model is much simpler
and cheaper than classical basic neuron
Network
okay how should we use deepal learning
to uh discover low dimensional dynamical
models so still we are going to follow
the idea of the three Rs right remember
reduce represent and and recover and we
have the high dimensional noisy image
data as our inputs right we put them
into an out encoder to reduce the
dimensionality nonlinearly and then we
have the low dimension of latent space
and the dat and states right and then we
try to do representation and in this
work we are simply you we are simply
using a multi-layer neuron Network to
approximate the map between the current
reduced State and the current uh
external action to the next reduced
State basically this neuron network is
trying to approximate uh a forward erer
scheme right and after this we use a
decoder to recover back to the images uh
I would like to emphasize that we have
the out encoder and the multi-layer
neuron Network for the dynamical model
both as deep chal learning models
basically we are embedding a
convolutional neuron Network here and a
multi-layer neuron Network here into
gion processes to enable uncertainty
quantification in this case both the uh
uncertainties in the encoding and the
uncertainties in the dynamic
approximation would be covered by the
Deep kernel learning models and we uh
together with all these three modules in
this big model we train them uh together
and try to test how we can handle
extracting dynamical systems out of high
dimensional image data okay we did uh
several task U several tests we added
noise uh directly onto the image data
and we also try to uh try to add noise
to the external control or external
actions or even we add noise to the
underlying Dynamics to make this system
stochastic and in all these cases our uh
our model gave us very clear and compact
representations of the low dimensional
Dynamics and also I would like to
emphasize that we have very clear Den
noising effect uh in the risk
reconstruct
images okay so this is I call this a
Gbox model because it is not blackbox
and we are we are having this deep
kernel learning model in the
representation step to approximate a
forward oler scheme so it is trying to
approximate certain dynamical uh
structure underlying our images right so
this is a g box but still we would like
to think whether we can incorporate more
physics into the training process to get
more physically consistent uh reduction
out of out of the data so this will
introduce our third method that we are
going to discuss today is is using
basing inference to to estimate the
reduced order
operators okay so we can start with an
example suppose you are trying to solve
uh wiscus Burgers equation you can use
your favorite special discretization for
wiscus burgers equation for example you
can use uh finite different Fin and
difference over space or finite volume
finite
elements whichever works uh for spal
discretisation and after the after this
step we will end up with a
uh dynamical system in the full order
sense which is quadratic right because
the uh
um riskus Burgers equation is a
quadratic um we also know that if we
have a linear reduced spaces once we
have projected the full order system
onto the linear reduced space we will Al
we will end up with a reduce of the
system being in the same formulation of
a quadratic structure only much reduced
the size so the quadratic uh the
polinomial structure of the equation
will still preserved we only have a
reduced
dimensionality uh if we recall how we do
this in n in in in intrusive mod
reduction actually we have to get the
access to the code uh to the full order
code to get the matrixes a uh h b and
Vector C and then formulate the reduce
all the system through numerical
projection and get the reduce all the
operators a h head B hat and and C hat
right and this is not something we want
to do because that's intrusive we may
not have the access in inside the full
order code that means we do not exactly
know about the full order operators a h
b and c but still we know that the
reduce of the system through linear
projection would would follow a
quadratic formulation so we need a way
to an alternative way to figure out to
estimate our we reduce all the
parameters a hat H Hat B had and C hat
actually the way we are resorting to is
called Data driven reduced order
operator inference the idea is like
following so first of all We Gather our
full order data for the full for the
full size vectors full size snap Q We
Gather the data of Q and then we use P
to compress our reduced basis V then we
re we rep we project our Q data onto the
V basis to get our reduced the data for
Q hat right and then we plug our qad
data into our reduced order system
formulation and then we try to minimize
the residual sum of squares for the for
the for the reduce of the system by
minimizing such a squared residual we
are going to have an estimate of the
reducer The Operators a hat H Hat B hat
and C hat that best match our Q hat data
reduce the data in the minimum residual
sense of course and in the end of the
day at the end of the day we will have
at least the square problem and of
course you can add
your uh your favorite uh regularization
as necessary to improve uh as as
necessary to improve the uh estimate of
our reduce that reduce all the
operators okay so this is a datadriven
learning process and of course we may
introduce a variety of uncertainties
inside this throughout this process for
example uh we may have uh noise in the
data of the full order Cube and after
the reduction the noise will will be
reduced a little bit as well but still
there there makes exist noise in the
reduced State date as well in qad uh on
the other hand as you can see here we
need to
approximate time derivatives to get time
derivative data in this loss function
that
means we have to perform for example
finite differences to evaluate this to
approximate these time derivatives out
of our state St data and this is going
to introduce approximation error which
is another source of uncertainty in our
data driven learning process uh also we
use the regularization and this is
another source of uncertainty and last
but not least uh we may have model M
specification for example if your
underlying system for your data is
actually a U third order system with a
minor third order term but now we are
assuming that the system is quadratic
and ignoring the third order term we
have a model M specification here right
so these are uh these are many sources
of the uncertainties that may be
introduced into this operator inference
framework this is why we want to do
uncertainty quantification we want to
upgrade our determinist or Point
estimate into a basing inference so that
we not only have a point estimate of our
redu operators but also a posterior
distribution to describe the Quantified
uncertainties okay uh so we started with
a very simple setup first of all we uh
Define the residual of our reduced s the
system as a gaan type noise uh in
addition to that we also Define our
prior on the uh reduce the operators as
the Gan joint Gan distribution with
predefined mean vector and Hyper primet
uh variance then naturally we resort to
the base Rule and have the posterior uh
distribution for our reduced order uh
operators with a new mean vector and a
cence matrix so if we look closer at the
posterior mean Vector we will see that
this is actually equivalent to a
deterministic list squares estimate with
the with t of regularization or the
estimator through read regression this
is a common sense in Bas inversion a
well-known result and in fact in
practice we often need uh such a t of
regularizer in our Opera inference
because first of all it may resolve the
issues where you condition the gr Matrix
D transpose D here uh if this D
transpose D is you conditioned we do
need such a regularizer to improve the
condition number because we have to
invert this Matrix right and in some
other cases we may also need the T of
regularizer to help stabilize the reduce
or the time integration
afterwards but even though but even even
we have such a useful uh T of
regularization we are still introducing
extra uncertainties into the operator
inference process right we want to to uh
quantify uh do the quantification of
uncertainties for the use of T of
regular risers actually if we can recall
the ton of regulariser is corresponding
to the prior of our basing inference
that means uh the definition of the
penalty coefficient for the regular
Riser is equivalent to choosing uh
good prior for our red are operators so
that means the quantifying the modeling
certainties introduced by the T of
regularization is naturally covered by
such a basin framework right and in this
case since we have a connection between
the regularization uh choosing and and
the prior choosing we can also use uh
the perspective from both uh statistical
learning and the physics based
simulation to help us do the
hyperparameter learning so after we have
the inference for our reduced order
operators we can sample we can sample
over this posterior distribution of
these parameters and have a lot of
samples individually and for each and
every them we can evaluate the reduce of
the Dynamics not only trying to
reconstruct the history but also predict
for the future stat uh and we have
Ensemble of such redu Solutions then we
can have the statistics uh of such uh
probalistic reduce order uh
solution we have tested this method in
several numerical examples I'm going to
uh show you one here this is a 2d single
injector combustion process right it's
rather complex physics in 2D we have
fuel and oxidizer coming into uh coming
into the tube from the left hand side
and the chemical reaction will take
place inside uh the tube
right and we were trying to use our
basing operator inference to have a low
dimensional dynamical representation of
this system as you can see from both the
first six P modes uh and also for uh the
x velocity at four critical locations uh
in terms of uh accuracy we have the
predictive mean quite close to the
underlying reference
uh not only for the Reconstruction of
the history data covered by the training
but also for the future States future
States for quite a long time and in
terms of uncertainty quantification we
can see that uh both the errors in the
mean prediction and the uncertainty band
are increasing in a similar way so this
means that the confidence level is
giving us meaningful uh indication about
how uncertainties are propagated from
the estimates of the reduce operators to
the time integration over
time
okay maybe you have already realized
when we did the basing inference uh we
uh explicitly involved the time
derivative data and it is often the case
that we do not have direct access to
time derivatives that means we often
need to use numerical differentiation
for example finding differences to
approximate time derivatives from the
reduced State data and this can work if
the data are perfect but what if we have
noisy or scarce data right in those
cases the fin an element approximations
of the time derivatives would be very
bad and this will further compromise the
quality of our operative inference uh
you may say that okay uh I know uh
neural Odes right in neural OD treatment
we are directly incorporating time
Integrations into the loss function we
directly uh we directly compare the
integrated uh states to the state data
basically we translating differentiation
into uh integration and then we use
either ad joint state or automatic
differentiation depending on how which
type of time integation either appro
either disate or continuous you use but
this all this means extra efforts in the
training stage so more recently together
with some of our collaborators we have
been trying to figure out a simple way
to address uh this issue so basically
what we want to improve the the
predictiveness when data are noisy and
or scarce basically when Fin and
difference uh can not really approximate
good time derivatives and here we are
thinking about a more generic setup for
dynamical systems here I'm writing a
dynamical system right and each and
every line of the equation is uh is
parameterized on the left hand side so
in this case the learning of the
dynamical system from the data is
basically posed as a basing inference
problem to estimate uh Theta I for each
and every
equation in each every equation in the
dynamical system okay so we want to
figure out a way to conveniently uh do
this basing inference without using
finite difference or other numerical
approximations of the time derivatives
so this is our goal and of course if you
consider this fi on the right hand side
as a quadratic uh structure and
this Theta I as our reduce all operators
and each XI is a reduced stage in the uh
reduced system so basically this system
is going to be representing our reduced
order system in the in the last couple
of slides but here we are considering a
more generic setup so here we are going
to uh again
use cion process to help us uh the
assumption is that each and every uh
State variable over time is a gion
process and it's well known in the gion
process community that um linear
operations on Gan processes will not
really change the Gan property so linear
operations or Gan process will remain
Gan so that means the joint distribution
between the state which is gion process
and it's time derivative will follow a
vector value cion process we just need
to act the time derivatives at the
proper locations in the
kernels okay and then we can use this to
help us Define a a new
likelihood okay so let's recall what a
likelihood is so likelihood is the
probability of
certain evidence like observations data
measurements or other types of
measurements given the primer
we want to estimate right this is the
likelihood function of our
parameters so let's consider what kind
of evidence we can have in this
scenario so first of all we have the
time series data in the data driven
sense right this is for cion process
regression we have the data so we can do
emulation and actually we have another
sort of evidence in this setup it is
actually the formulation of our
differential equations so we can use the
differential equation constraints given
in this form as a an additional uh
evidence to be incorporated into our
likelihood as we just discussed the
joint distribution of the T the state
and the time derivative will follow
again a gaan process and we can use this
Gan process this new joint gan process
to Define our joint likelihood we just
need to replace the right hand
side of the dynamical
system to we just need to use the right
hand side of our dynamical system to
replace the time derivative and in this
case we are trying to match the left
hand side and the right hand side of the
dynamic system together and in this
sense we are incorporating differential
equations uh constraints into the
definition of our
likelihood okay so this is how we Define
our likelihood in a new way and of
course in the end of at the end of the
day we are going to have a basing
inference again we have the prior as a
joint uh normal distribution and the
newly likelihood as in the last uh slide
and then we have the postera once we
have the posterior distribution for the
parameters Theta I we can have a basing
predictions by sampling over such a
posterior Theta I right so actually we
can um look more carefully at our
posterior distributions for for our
parameters I actually uh rearrange a
little bit uh the formulation of our
post posterior uh distribution for Theta
I as you can see here the maximum poster
or map estimate of our Theta I is
actually equivalent to an estimate
through generalized the least squares
regularized by a tonov regularizer again
and it in the generalized the Leist
squares formulation here the target term
D hat here is actually the mean estimate
of our time derivatives through our gion
process emulation and the weight Matrix
in our generalized least squares is
actually the cence Matrix for the
estimated uh time derivatives through GP
so in this sense it
means uh we are implicitly still trying
to approximate time derivatives but this
approximation of the time derivatives is
through the uh
smoothing uh by aulion process emulation
and more importantly the the
uncertainties introdu introduced by this
smoothening process is automatically
covered Auto atically included in such a
basing inference framework so in the end
of the day we have an
estimate uh if you have we have an
estimate that covered all the
uncertainties involved in this in this
learning process uh that means if you
have a scars or noisy data uh but you
have a very good ging process you can be
relaxed and the ging process will help
you uh denoise the data and give you a
very good implicit uh estimation of the
time derivative and using such a Time
derivative estimation you can have a
good estimates of of your reduce all the
operators or the parameters in the
dynamic
system uh we have tested this method in
a few examples this is still ongoing
work but I would like to uh share with
you some of our preliminary results so
first example here is a lotka Vera
system uh we are going to estimate Alpha
Beta Delta and Gamma for for parameters
in this system using our newly defined
likelihood through gotion processes as
you can see here we when we have no
noise in the system uh if we use either
a lot of data or much reduced amount of
data um is the results are all very good
very decent and then we try to make it
more challenging we increase the noise
level to
10% uh as you can see if we use all the
data we have results are still good 10%
of the data used uh quite nice and 5% of
the data uh there could be some error
but the trend is still good then we try
to make it even more challenging we in
increase the level noise level to 20%
with all of the data still good results
10% of the data reasonable 5% of of the
data uh the error becomes larger and
larger uh but in the but in the end we
can see that our method is quite robust
with respect to noise level and and the
sparse data right you can make it more
and more challenging and the method can
still handle quite challenging cases and
how about we consider reduce all
modeling here I'm showing you a very
simple case is a heat equation linear
equation right and the reduce all model
structure is is linear right right and
we want to do the estimate of our reduce
reduce order uh parameters a hat B hat
and C hat here right and as you can see
we can uh when we have quite some noise
uh in the in the full order States once
we use our newly defined gion process
based likelihood we can have a very
decent estimate of the reducer the
system once we recover back to the full
order size uh even at Lo pointwise uh
local points we can still extract
reasonable uh uh Dynamic Behavior out of
the noisy data right not only to in the
in the Reconstruction of the history but
also for the predictions for the future
States and what if we uh reduce the
number of data still as you can see the
the results are very good so it seems
like ction process are very good at
uh Den noising uh and this can help us
uh Define go around go around the
derivative uh derivative difficulty
derivative difficulty in the in the in
the time series when the data annoys or
or scars and uh this can give us very
good
results in terms of in terms of
predictions so so still these are some
very uh recent results
and uh I would like to hear some of your
ideas opinions or suggestions and I
guess this is about what I want to share
with you uh today uh a few words as a
summary some take-home information so
today we have been uh discussing uh
several different types of model
reduction techniques in a probalistic
sense using probalistic machine learning
methods the first one was about blackbox
method using ging process circuit
modeling and second one was the gray box
using deep peral learning to represent
low dimensional dynamical systems out of
noisy images and the third third method
was basing operator inference uh
basically using basing inference to
estimate reduce all operators with know
physical structures and in the end we
discussed how to use gum processes to
incorporate differential uh equation
constraints into the likelihood
definition so that we can improve the
predictiveness uh especially when the
data are noisy or F okay thank you very
much and I look forward to your comments
criticism suggestions and discussions
thank you thank you thank you thank you
so much for the wonderful talk memo I
enjoyed it a lot um let's have a Q&A
session
um all right uh Kevin has a question in
chat room yeah I will
um we will you know give a chance a a
bit after this K is asking in slides
1516 1516 okay I'm what is the
yeah he's asking what is the loss
function to train neural network and GP
hyper parameters that's thank you very
much thank you very much this is a very
good question because the L function was
too long so I didn't put here uh we
train this three models uh Al together
so we have to combine the loss functions
for this three uh Parts all together so
I can I can tell you what what they are
and of course you can refer to the paper
to see more detail so first of all we
need to make sure that the encoding
decoding is making sense right so we
need a uh MSE to to match the
Reconstruction of the encoding decoding
this is one second one we have to uh
make sure this approximation of the uh
fold oler is making sense so we have MS
for this multi-layer perception as well
this is the second one the third one uh
will start to uh train the gum processes
right how to train gum process
hyperparameter basically you can use
maximum marginal likelihood or uh the
minimum of negative log marginal
likelihood
right we have then we have to
incorporate the negative log margin
likelihood of all these cion processes
into the loss function and in the end we
have to use variational inference to
estimate the probability right so the we
we also need to use elbow to to replace
the the K Divergence so all these terms
will be combined together for the
training of this big model and you also
feel free to refer to the to the paper
for more details but this was roughly
the spirit yeah okay somean has a second
question if you can go to slide
yeah this beian inference is based on a
prescribed redu St model uh with
uncertainty model parameters as your
basan inference quantify the model Miss
specification for example missing high
order or financial terms Etc uh thank
you this is definitely a very good
question and we have been thinking about
this question as well uh so of course in
our very first work we simply used an
independent White Noise right and it was
not really uh covering the model M
specification and of course you can
upgrade a little bit and you are you can
use a gan process to replace a white
noise for this error term so basically
that's going to that's basically trying
to approximate your model M
specification or your closure as a g
process Tate you can do that but that's
still uh limited uh we are still trying
to figure out better ways to do to do it
but based on such a framework the best
you can do is to try to use the gum
process to approximate this Epsilon I as
a Sur model for the closure all right
yeah thank you um uh I think next one
was uh ABI J um you raise your hand
before so if you can unmute yourself and
ask question that would be awesome yeah
please can you hear me yeah yeah yeah
yeah thank you so much for amazing
presentation uh so uh you touched upon
um extracting the basis uh using pod the
ging process if I not
WR yeah uh so uh say for for example uh
if a snapshot Matrix has Million by
million data points uh where you can't
do uh D transpose D I think you're doing
a d transpose D to reduce the dimension
of the Matrix to extract the
pre-processing or uh P modes from it uh
so I just need your opinion on this say
for example you have a million by
million data points in your snapshot
Matrix where you can't do
dersy what is a viable pre-processing
tool to go for like team or PCA if
you're
using some some conventional ones it's
going to take a longer time to get those
basis is or interpolations point out of
it so what's your take on this when you
have Million by million data points or
something
like okay thank you for your question
and let me repeat your question and see
I'm understanding correctly okay so you
have a lot of data points so that means
this d uh this D Matrix will be narrow
but very long right uh so and if you do
D transpose the computational cost is
very large and how how do you deal with
how deal with this okay thank you
um we haven't uh we haven't met such a
difficulty yet U but I have some ideas
how to deal with this uh so for example
you don't you don't need all of them to
to to estimate your reduce order
operators right you can take one
snapshot uh among several right every
like
100 steps you can take one if that can
still give you a good estimate why not
right or you can use some other uh
techniques for example you can use a
boost wrapping or Ensemble uh to to have
so each time you only have a subset of
the samples and have an estimate and you
do this several times uh to form an
ensemble and have a more probabilistic
estimate of your redu uh operators this
is this is another uh strategy I can
think of and actually in in Cindy um
they have
already they have already beg to to use
uh boost wrapping and Ensemble to to
deal with this um and another strategy
is actually our our new method here
right you can simply reduce the number
of data and let gion process to help you
uh interpolate and extrapolate yeah uh
to interpolate to interpolate in this
case yeah yeah thank you thank you so
much for sharing I'll look into those
thanks listening to that reply I was
simply curious why can't you just use
the htpc like distributed those data and
then do the D transpose
D yeah that could also be an option yeah
okay yeah all right next question from
John have you tried or compared against
other system ident identification
methods like ID u m Moi I don't even
know how to pronounce it
um mo mo I can tell sorry I used an
acronym Yu so Observer Comm filter
identification and a multivariate output
error State
space well um are you aware of that
mango uh I'm I'm sorry maybe
I have limited knowledge to to to
address this uh but I a comment I can I
I I can I can provide is that basically
uh our method here for example for the
scussion process likelihood definition
method this can be embedded into a lot
of methods right this is just a new way
to define a likelihood uh if you are you
wherever you need likelihood you may
think whether this likelihood can be
used in your favorite method right for
example we can use use this likelihood
in operator inference like I did before
or uh you can use a similarly defined
likelihood in Cindy right it's it's also
it's also an option uh so I would say
that our ction process based the
likelihood definition is more like a
plugin right you can use this to plug
you can plug this into your inference
framework if it is okay to use yeah this
is a comment I can I can provide and of
course feel feel free to write me an
email about your specific considerations
and I'm happy to
discuss okay yeah for example will you
go at mtech next week I'll be
there yeah see
where mortech 2023 in
Paris I'm sorry I'm not I'm not I'm not
going I guess okay no I show you an
email yeah yeah we wrote email before
right so I I know your email let's
communicate B on that that's right we
did emails in the past thank you so much
great
presentation thank you thank you awesome
awesome um can I ask
question sure sure go ahead all right um
so you me one time in your presentation
you mentioned that deep Coral learning
training course is less than beian
neural network but I can see that
because the beian neural network is is
really really expensive to train but I I
see that deep conal learning still um
has the component of neural network and
it is combined with the GP later on so
the training of the um dkl the Deep
cornal learning it it should be as as
expensive as just training the normal
neural network yeah is yeah I think so I
think so uh
it's indeed indeed we for example we use
the maximum marginal likelihood to train
this manifold GP so basically that's
comparable to the training of a
deterministic neuron network but but
with a different loss function so this
is cheaper than the training of a Bas in
neur network right I see I see okay the
computational cost is saved in this
sense I see yeah but the you know the
deterministic neural network training of
that is not a easy task as you increase
the data size because you have to solve
the nonlinear op problem true that's
true that's true so so you still have a
issue of
scaling um in that
sense uh I would admit yes yes yeah
because because of the neuron Network
existing existing in this model yeah
right right um but I mean you know other
compression technique I mean a lot of
times you know you you you presented
three or four different methods um I
think two or three was you know based on
the Pod like the linear compression
because we like
it we like it because the training of
that is you know very a lot less complex
than training the neural network but it
has a disadvantage like it cannot
accurately represent the ation Dynamics
for example what the
CH is yeah decaying slow yeah yeah yes
but in that sense in that sense deep
conal learning would be beneficial
because you're using the neur network to
compress um yeah any comments on that I
have very mixed feeling uh some of my my
work I do use Auto encoder or similar
tools for nonlinear manifold learning
because they are useful and popular of
course uh but uh for for example if you
use an convolution AO encoder here you
don't have as good as as good error
control as in p right many things are
unknown yeah and and if you want to do a
more physically meaningful projection
onto the nonlinear latent space of
course you can do you can do uh
um Leist squares patch of Goring that's
one way uh so I guess yonsu knows that
very well yeah that's one way but uh
it's not always convenient either uh
especially when you are neuron Network
encoder is very very complex and the
projection could be very tricky and if
we do a blackbox learning or or we call
or black box or g box learning we are
missing some Physics so I have a mixed
the feeling about it so if we have
linear PCA we can do the linear
projection in a very decent way of
course it's not the best way uh
basically we have to com compromise
either here or that or that maybe one
the someone in the audience come come
with us with with a very good idea maybe
that can be re
Revolution yeah revolutionary yeah I I
don't have a clear answer for that yet I
I don't think anyone has a clear answer
for that yeah so I I think I ask you
difficult question um I I love the um
you know you know your method of you
know deal with the noise data um
basically using the uh scalation process
to smooth those data and then um you
know get the robust accuracy um I I saw
in experiment you you tried up to 10%
noise level yeah have you tried to
increase that noise level like maybe
100% noise
level yeah I I I showed 20% we also
tried a little bit more 30% but uh
that's not going to work going to work
very well uh so here so this is how we
roughly Define the level of noise
basically uh so so we enrage the the
solution data to get a rough order of
magnitude of the solution data and we so
10% means that 10% of that right right
would be the standard deviation for the
White Noise we add onto the onto the
data in that sense if we increase to
100% the data not really making sense at
all right yeah yeah so in this sense 20
30% would already be quite quite large
and in reality even though we have data
in the real world sensing system but it
wouldn't be so so large right you
introduce some error but the the level
is is up to some limit okay so so 20%
think you think it's a reasonable no I
20 to % would be a reasonable I see set
up yeah okay sounds good we we actually
have a recent um work is about to be
published uh is we are introducing
another way of dealing with those noise
data as well you're using gion process
um but ALS but we are using um the week
C like the
umal yeah integral integral form of the
you know sparse identification of yeah
yeah uh basically you have your PD and
you have a weight you have a test
functions and do part integration by
part so that the noise will come from
this counterpart to the other one right
yeah yeah exactly but we we use the Wix
in the latent space so so we do the
compression first like either pod or
Auto encoder and then apply the Wix in
the in the latent space reduce space
there when we apply the noise level like
up to 50% even like higher we we we we
got remarkable accuracy very surprising
accuracy so I I will definitely share
those work with you thank you that would
be very very very helpful but I I do
actually have a question for that uh so
if you use the week CD it's very
critical uh how to choose the test
functions
right right right we we use the like the
pie wise the compactly supported uh the
basis functions and it is sensitive to
how we uh change the radius like the
width of that
compactness um so you have to tune for
that uh depending with the applications
yeah yeah yeah that's that's my
impression too is very good to to have
this confirmed thank you thank you yeah
um maybe last question from me uh so you
you showed the 2D single injector com
combustion process yeah if you can go to
that slide I don't know the slide number
yeah just one yeah what is y here y1 Y2
Y3 y4 Y which so in the definition of q
of C Vector is a fractions of the the
fractions of the so it's a two- face FL
yeah awesome awesome yeah is the
fractions of the of the components yeah
like the volume fractions yeah yeah
that's great and you you apply the P you
use the p
yeah we did the P yes yeah this is yeah
complicated yes this is indeed the case
where P may not be the best the best
choice but we use a lot of beauty modes
in the end to guarantee the
approximation is still
decent and I mean you you're doing
extrapolation too like in in yeah we're
doing extrapolation too we used the 60
each PUD M if I remember correctly I
have to refer to the paper to to refresh
my memory but we use indeed use a lot of
p mod oh okay awesome I I loved it so I
think we need to talk about this
yeah all right um any other questions
from
audience um if not let's thank our
speaker um mangu for the wonderful talk
and um you know all the nice research he
presented thank you so much um thank you
thank you thank you for the invitation
and all the nice discussions and
Communications thank you awesome okay
let me push the start button